we are indeed with the new co-leader at
least until that game between larry
christensen and chabot of ends that is
dimitri gorevich dimitri welcome back
what happened today it seemed like uh a
gift was uh given to you merry christmas
gifts yes
you know i played once with alexander
onychuck who has a great sense of humor
and i made some
some very aggressive move but not a good
one and he said that it was in i think
in seattle in the early 2000s
and he said
uh when you made this move i wanted to
resign immediately
which didn't mean of course but you know
it means that you're not supposed to do
things like that so i was thinking that
watch out for knight d5 but that said no
no bishop on the five can't do that i
mean the under no i don't see any
scenario and i can do that um so it was
just a blind spot from here
but i got you know when you when you
blunder it's usually one situation is
not so great
so i think i'm not so sure i want to
check it up but uh i think that my
passion started getting
not work maybe a little better oh
absolutely no yeah i was because before
it was it wasn't it wasn't the case you
were not worse at all after knight to e8
that's for sure yes but before he played
rock hc1 i'm not better definitely it's
a
tough position if it's a little bit it's
but of course
according to my understanding yeah
dimitri well this game uh has only one
story but tomorrow there is a big game
against larry christensen in the last
round how do you feel about that game
what is the strategy going into that
game i i don't have too many
too much a strategy i would like to play
a game i would like to fight
uh you know if it's possible because
yesterday it wasn't the fight gregory
out played me very nicely and won a game
and he played very well i didn't play
but
but
and he's a very difficult opponent for
me he's very strong and he's difficult
opponent for me uh but i know one player
who is even worse for me but
unfortunately he's not playing our
tournament he's sitting in that room
nice again remember back-to-back i was
still completely one position i was very
lucky to have them maybe we'll be able
to coax him into the event
next year just to watch him but
every year we're trying the same
strategies maybe we'll be able to get to
him at some point about larry i enjoy
playing larry larry
right now this is a great game because
two wild players two attacking players
attacking players is very rare
occurrence because people want to play
position again
even the best players like yes
don't call him but let's ask you about
this position actually what do you think
larry will do will he take on e6
or will he go knight to e4 okay i'll
tell you this i doubt about 94 which is
possible it might be a good move but
again
you know larry he wrote the book
you have to consider right away knight
takes a six h take g6 and knight takes
off seven which probably doesn't work
but something similar something might uh
it's kind of
uh upsetting for white to play kind of
disappointing not upsetting to play
knight g4
kind of because also you sometimes some
simple moves like bishop takes f5 kind
of might be a good move i doubt it but
it might you know so my impression which
is i i during this game by the way i
didn't see it other games at all and i
think it was a good decision
to
do distracting very because they're very
interesting um
i would
expect something oh
he did he did take one he did not know
it's just it's it's analysis it's just
an hour
we're still waiting to see what his move
critical position critical position
and h6 is putting a lot of pressure i
have to say on larry only 26 minutes for
him we know that he's thinking about
that move knight takes e6 but
yes it might not work and it might and
it's kind of then he had to play knight
g4 and then black
might play g5 probably and
create a nice
normal position
at least from a psychological uh point
of view if you do have to play uh knight
to e4 yeah and don't abide by your
instincts well unfortunately it's going
to be difficult for the remainder of the
game dmitry thank you very much uh for
joining us yeah i say something about it
we have a tournament it's rare uh people
who we can call
attacking player it's it's a
reactiveness because it's extremely
difficult people they will play rook f1
f2 sing for one hour and then play rook
f1 f2 and then suddenly sacrifice we
have three people in this tournament
which we call attacking player
it's definitely
larry number one it's definitely shabolf
they're taking a lot of pressure they're
taking root of this and definitely nick
but nick is not in good form so
i compare them with my students i
compare them that a regular player is
like a horse rider
but attacking play is like a bull rider
so you have to sit like 10 seconds on
the ball but it's extremely so it it was
like 8 000
professional or half semi-professional
horse riders it was one only one
thousand bull rides it was like 20 years
ago so compare them they take a
tremendous chance but it's pretty
enjoyable to watch them you know
absolutely absolutely and they run fast
that's for sure i'm not
you're
in
of a strategical player one they're
trying you know it was a co-leading
position big game tomorrow we're looking
for yeah i love when they put the guys
who is like make one more game
no no way near the first play
but because you have one more round
you're temporarily convinced okay thank
you thank you thank you wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute dean edema
take it easy relax first of all i loved
your analogy between horse writing and
bull writing speaking of bull riders
tomorrow you're going to have this big
game regardless of the outcome of
larry's game today just tell me how you
match up with larry i know over the
decades you guys have played plenty of
u.s championship events what's your
score the story which is hard to uh i
always think about it but that is for me
the most interesting guy to play you
know uh first when i came to united
states
42 years ago
and uh larry was
already a very famous guy he played gold
junior championship got second place at
that time and he was
um
at that time extremely strong in 1981
one of the was one of the best players
in the world you know
no doubt about it he played in daenerys
he made eight out of 11.
uh tied for this karpov he lost a game
against him he shouldn't lose it and he
beat great players boris paske grigorich
what was you know uh
portis you know i mean he was he made
out eight out of 11 he was he was
amazing so
in my first game against larry in u.s
open he just showed me
the highest class he beat me in position
which was no worse for me but his he
made some trick which i didn't see and
then that was classical and game
gigglish fisher when uh
official analyze a few hours he didn't
happen and he couldn't find uh at the
royal and i did the same thing in
eurozone analyze the whole night but it
was rock and ji pawn against uh uh rock
which is which is uh it was
unfortunately lost but nothing could do
and then
i thought it was just basically
impossible to beat him at that time uh i
remember once i made the drawing and the
rock and pony was two points down but it
was a position from a theoretical draw
so i said oh it's like to be in a game
against him then i accidentally beat him
in san francisco 1987. if i didn't beat
he would win the tournament so
but but his score was absolutely great
again against me so uh draw was like a
win
but then something happened i got lucky
in the game
in one game and then
in the us championship i beat him a few
times in a row
you know lucky
not very lucky and once skipped landed
the rock but i realized it's uh my
knight was gonna be something to play
rugby then i realized it's actually a
common blunder it's like bereaved the
same thing the knight was on youtube you
put rock on the one so i thought okay i
would like you but not that lucky
and then finally i won in 1996 i won a
nice game against him it just was kinda
but it was a really good game it was my
one one of my best
by the way in 1996 we had a tournament
seven participants from this tournament
out of then played in 1996. except of
novik of courier of the nation country
vladimir kuban who was of course a young
guy but lived also in a different
country and max lugi didn't play in that
term because he was working he was
working in the bank but seven people
played the tournament and it was very
interesting how they played it and that
was one of my best tournaments because
if i accidentally would beat uh
alexis manis last year and i would be a
champion you know it i was better at one
point but it was you know
gregory had much more chance to win that
again than me but
alex wouldn't unfortunately he's not
here but i said malinsky on it anyway so
larry is tremendously
interesting opponent uh even if you
don't beat him whatever you know which
is hard to beat him he's a great great
player one of the very very best
and
uh
i i remember that he couldn't beat me
for 22 years i was called i couldn't
believe my eyes you know and then
finally in 2010 my last u.s championship
he just crushed me he showed me that my
understanding of sicilian very far
from
you know
perfect
from the other good guys huh
so
by the way sicilian now it's not doing
very well and i'm so glad that i don't
place a city anymore in this tournament
because it was the last chance i was
sure that uh my opponent igor played
basic force it would be situation and i
thought oh so good no certainly dimitri
uh big game tomorrow will let you go get
your rest get your preparation going and
get ready for the big clash yes yes
thank you very much yes